bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir et
plutôt un homme rare dans les médias il
pilote l'un des groupes les plus
importants à l'Assemblée nationale
bonsoir Jean-Paul mettei bonsoir et
merci d'être là vous êtes le président
des 51 députés modem à l'Assemblée le
parti de François Bayrou a lieu
indispensable à la majorité macroniste
qu'avez-vous fait depuis un an de cette
position stratégique on en parle
ensemble dans la deuxième partie mais on
commence ce soir par le partage de la
valeur c'est la nouvelle expression
consacrée pour désigner la participation
et l'intéressement des salariés aux
bénéfice de leur entreprise l'accord
national conclut entre patronat et
syndicat va être transposé dans la loi
les députés en débattent en ce moment en
commission à l'Assemblée alors qu'est-ce
qui va changer très concrètement pour
les salariés les gains de pouvoir
d'achat feront-ils suffisant pour
compenser l'envoler des prix grands
débats dans un instant avec mes invités
sur ce plateau avant de retrouver 20h15
vous le savez les affranchis pour leur
pack parti pris et puis dans Bourbon
Express ce soir le plan caché de la
macronie pour déloger l'insomnie Éric
Coquerel de la tête de la commission des
finances bigre on verra ça ensemble vous
êtes prêts Jean-Paul métaye ça vous
regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
et si l'on partageait vraiment le gâteau
quelle part pour les salariés qui font
la richesse de leur entreprise
l'association capital travail grands
débat initié il y a bien longtemps par
le général de Gaulle après-guerre qui
resurgit aujourd'hui dans un contexte
d'inflation et après la crise des
retraites le partage de la valeur les
dividendes du travail de quoi parle-t-on
précisément combien peut-on espérer et
comment beaucoup de questions se soient
dans ce débat à la fois politique et
économique bonsoir Clémence guetter
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
député la France insoumise du
Val-de-Marne vous débattez ce soir avec
Gilbert 7 bonsoir bonsoir économiste et
professeur à Neoma Business School
bonsoir Agnès Brika bonsoir vous êtes
ambassadrice à la participation et à
l'intéressement qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire en un mot un mot il faut diffuser
des dispositifs de partage de valeur
depuis la loi du 16 août 2022 ou 4 5
dispositifs ont été présentés donc pas
faire de la pédagogie grâce à vous ce
soir enfin bonsoir Jean-François Mathieu
bienvenue vous êtes professeur à
l'Université Paris importer on Sorbonne
et spécialistes des syndicats les
syndicats presque tous les syndicats ont
signé cet accord ont le verra Jean-Paul
Mathey vous êtes entièrement parti
prenante dans ce débat puisque je sais
bien que c'est sujet passionnent le
parti de François Bayrou le modèle c'est
une c'est une vieille Marotte et puis
vous avez aussi des propositions vous en
avez fait sur sur le la taxation des
dividendes c'est atelier pour l'instant
sans écho du président de la République
on commence par planter le décor après
la le salé de la réforme des retraites
le sucrées de la démocratie sociale il a
deux secondes le chrono de la côte c'est
parti
bonsoir mon cher Stéphane je vous invite
à vous retourner pour écouter Stéphane
blackovski dans son billet ça fait 6
mois qu'on accuse du gouvernement de
refuser tout dialogue avec les syndicats
et bien en ce moment il a l'occasion de
prouver le contraire en effet début
février alors qu'on était pourtant au
début de la bataille des retraites le
patronat et tous les syndicats sauf la
CGT on se finit un accord national pour
un meilleur partage des richesses dans
l'entreprise qu'on appelle le partage de
la valeur faut dire qu'aujourd'hui la
situation est assez injuste ne serait-ce
que parce que les salariés qui
travaillent dans des entreprises de plus
de 50 personnes eux ont touche une
participation c'est obligatoire et c'est
pas le cas par ailleurs donc on donne on
arrive à des chiffres ou tomber très
grandes entreprises 88% des salariés
effectivement touche d'une manière d'une
autre une forme de partage de la valeur
dans les petites entreprises on en reste
seulement à 20%. donc évidemment les
partenaires sociaux sont dit que ça
serait mieux si les entreprises entre 11
et 49 salariés donc puissent elles aussi
offrir un partage de la valeur donc sous
différentes formes il y a la
participation bénéfice si l'entreprise
fait des bénéfices ça peut être de
l'intéressement qu'on employeur fixe un
objectif et qu'on l'atteint et puis la
fameuse prime Macron qui maintenant
était rebaptisée prime de partage de la
valeur la PPV donc de son côté le
gouvernement lui il s'efface il a juste
promis de traduire fidèlement cet accord
entre les partenaires sociaux dans un
projet de loi et donc en fin depuis 6
mois Olivier du socle peut dire qu'il
est sur la même ligne que les syndicats
le dialogue social s'est ouvert il n'a
pas été interrompu pendant toute cette
période et il a permis d'aboutir un
accord c'est la raison pour laquelle je
présente ce texte devant vous avec un
principe simple l'accord et rien que
l'accord faut dire que le patron a comme
les syndicats ont prévenu si le projet
de loi devait modifier l'accord qu'ils
ont signé ensemble alors là non la CFDT
a dit ça serait un croche-pied la
démocratie sociale le Medef a même parlé
de coup de poignard dans le dos sauf
qu'aujourd'hui c'est mise en garde des
partenaires sociaux ça se retombe plutôt
contre l'opposition qui elle aimerait
bien modifier le projet de loi de
l'améliorer la nupaisse par exemple dit
ben non si on veut vraiment partager la
valeur c'est pas des primes c'est des
augmentations de salaires qu'il faut il
y a bien sûr aussi la question des
supers profits il y a pas que la du
peste qui réfléchit la question c'est
que Jean-Paul Mattei il réfléchit aussi
parce que dans ce projet de loi même en
cas de projet exceptionnel et bien il y
a pas un partage automatique il y a
obligation d'ouvrir des négociations
enfin bon c'est pas parce qu'on ouvre
des négociations qu'on obtient
satisfaction bref du côté de la nupes en
fait on enrage de voir que le le
gouvernement s'abrite derrière les
partenaires sociaux pour refuser tout
changement son projet de loi on écoute
Mathias Tavel vous êtes des hypocrites
parce que vous vous cachez derrière cet
accord national interprofessionnel comme
alibi de démocratie sociale alors que
vous venez d'écraser les syndicats les
manifestants et l'Assemblée nationale
pour imposer la retraite à 64 ans alors
côté gouvernement contraire c'est
l'inverse évidemment une gazon de plus
de essayer de tourner la page des
retraites puis pour Elisabeth Bank c'est
l'occasion d'afficher sa fibre sociale
je vous rappelle que dans le temps elle
était de gauche alors juste un petit
bémol sur les déclarations Elisabeth
borne sur quelle exagère quand même un
peu voir beaucoup le montant de la
fameuse prime de partage de la valeur on
écoute la prime de partage de la valeur
qu'on a voté à l'été dernier à
bénéficier à 5,5 millions de salariés en
2022 pour un montant moyen de près de
800 euros par mois
800 euros par mois alors oui je
comprends qu'elle fasse très fier de sa
de sa mesure si elle pensait évidemment
mais c'est pas moi c'est 800 euros par
an évidemment donc on s'était déjà
mélangés au gouvernement dans les
chiffres sur les retraites faudrait pas
que ça recommence d'autant que ce sonore
il est affiché sur le site du
gouvernement vous voyez où on répète
tranquillement cette
erreur cela dit le débat ne fait
commencer et peut-être que parmi vous
certains trouvent que cette idée des 800
euros par mois n'est pas si mauvaise
merci
ce soir merci merci beaucoup Stéphane
Gilbert 7 on clarifie le débat pour
commencer distinction
participation intéressante on n'y
connaît rien expliquez-nous monsieur le
professeur
je pense que vous soyez tout à fait
d'expliquer cela mais les deux les deux
dispositifs sont vraiment très
différents et d'ailleurs la
participation est un dispositif qui a
été voulu par le général de Gaulle
lui-même et ça avait donné lieu à
l'ordonnance de 1967 c'est l'idée que
pour décrisper pour déconflictualiser
les relations de travail il faut donner
un intérêt commun aux détenteur de
l'entreprise des actions d'entreprise et
aux travailleurs comment on les
associent bien sûr au fait que quand il
y a des profits les travailleurs
puissent gagner plus d'argent et bien
sûr les détenteurs de capital peuvent
aussi gagner plus d'argent par
l'augmentation de la valeur de leur
entreprise ou par la distribution de
dividendes l'assiette de participation
c'est les profits de l'entreprise
bénéfice l'entreprise vous voyez quelque
chose de très très particulier il y a
une formule un petit peu complexe pour
définir le montant de participation qui
est accordée au travailleur
l’intéressement peut être basé sur
n'importe quel objectif intermédiaire
décider par l'accord collectif
d'intéressement ça peut être le fait de
consommer moins de feuilles de papier et
de ramette de papier pour pour des
objectifs je dirais climatiques ça peut
être vous voyez une quantité de choses
décidées par les partenaires sociaux à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise même si une
entreprise ne fait pas de bénéfice
l'objectif d'intéressement atteint
impliquera bien sûr le paiement de la
prime d'intéressement ce qui est pas le
cas pour la participation bénéfice d'un
côté pour la participation objective de
l'autre objectif d'ailleurs de
déconflictualisation des relations
sociales est important dans un pays
comme la France la France et le pays le
plus
rituel de tous les pays avancés si on
mesure cette conflictualité par exemple
par le nombre de jours perdus en moyenne
du fait de grève ou de la récollectif de
travail et bien sur les trois dernières
décennies en moyenne la France et le
pays qui est en tête non on continue la
pédagogie avec vous à on se situe où on
dit général de Gaulle on se souvient du
contexte il s'agissait aussi de réduire
les effets négatifs du capitalisme il y
avait aussi un parti communiste qui
était très fort à l'époque on est bon
sur le sujet ou au contraire nos voisins
européens je pense au pays du Nord font
bien mieux que nous moi je trouve qu'on
est plutôt bon en ce qui concerne nos
entreprises puisqu'on est descendu au
niveau de la participation de 100
salariés de l'époque de De Gaulle à 50
salariés ce qui va pas c'est en dessous
de 50 salariés et là il y a eu un vrai
travail qui a été mené depuis justement
presque novembre on va dire 2022 ou
l'ensemble des organisations patronales
et salariales ont reçu un courrier du
gouvernement leur demandant de se réunir
de négocier et on a devenu un accord
février 2023 donc un rapport rapide
quand on regarde ils sont mis d'accord
patronat et salariés pour dire en
dessous de 49 salariés et bien on se
doit de mettre un des dispositifs
partagent de valeur dans les 5 qui ont
été présentés dans la loi d'août 2022 et
la participation devient obligatoire oui
justement poursuivez il y a la prime de
partage de valeur dont on a bien de
parler même si les 800 euros on sait
bien que c'est pas par mois c'est pour
l'année mais il y a ensuite
l'intéressement il y a bien sûr la
participation mais on oublie
l'abonnement on le salarié donne un euro
pardon que le l'employeur peut en donner
jusqu'à trois donc ça on l'oublie ça
fonctionne l'abonnement l'abonnement
l'abondement pardonnez-moi et puis enfin
on a l'actionnariat salarié on en parle
jamais assez quoi exactement alors c'est
justement rentrer dans le capital des
entreprises on voit un certain nombre
d'entreprises qui sont souvent cotés des
gros ETI mais ça peut être des startups
aujourd'hui et entreprises de taille
intermédiaire dans le capital de ces
sociétés et au moment où on part à la
retraite et bien on vend ces actions
puisque en général ce sont des sociétés
qui sont cotées en bourse alors je vais
vous demander de me donner et j'arrive
aux politiques juste après votre votre
sentiment sur l'ambition de cet accord
il y a de la démocratie sociale ça on
peut s'en féliciter ça compte dans une
démocratie même si la CGT n'a pas signé
suffisamment ambitieux selon vousen
Becker cet accord alors ambitieux dans
la mesure où il y a une égalité qui doit
se faire au niveau des salariés
puisqu'il faut jamais oublier qu'on a
plus de quand même 80% d'entreprises qui
ont moins de 50 salariés donc il faut
avoir un respect de l'égalité en disant
on redescend les seuils jusqu'à 11 après
on parlera on était juste ça donc pour
moi dans l'égalité le principe même
c'est juste cette ambitieux c'est autre
chose on n'a pas donné de Quantum c'est
quoi un quantum c'est à dire quel est le
montant certains m'ont même parlé de 10
euros ça suffirait ah non il y a donc un
principe il n'y a pas de Quantum et on
peut imaginer qu'à ce moment-là que ça
soit pas aussi ambitieux qu'on le
voulait le quantum c'est quoi c'est le
seul minimal c'est le montant le montant
merci n'est qu'un des dispositifs de
partage valeur ça soit 10 euros et là ce
serait le summum de la caricature
Clémence guetter on y est la démocratie
sociale celle que vous réclamiez dans
l'hémicycle ils ont tous signé c'est à
peu près 70% des syndicats présentatifs
pas la CGT l'accord rien que l'accord
c'est ce qu'il demande des deux côtés
vous allez le dénaturer dans l'hémicycle
bon on va amander on est là pour amender
je doute que ça require recueille
beaucoup de suffrages je pense que nous
allons être minoritaire sur ce sujet
parce qu'on a déjà eu l'occasion de
parler des questions de prix mais de
salaire dans le projet de loi pouvoir
d'achat de l'été dernier et déjà les
macronistes étaient alliés au
rassemblement national et à la droite
pour voter contre l'augmentation du SMIC
etc donc on voit à peu près ce que les
rapports de force peuvent donner sur ce
type de sujet je veux juste revenir sur
le cadre de l'accord déjà les syndicats
posent tous la question que nous nous
posons c'est-à-dire des primes d'accord
mais c'est insuffisant et je vais y
revenir ce qui important ce serait
l'augmentation des salaires dans ce pays
parce que ça ne crée pas les mêmes
droits notamment c'est les entreprises
pour la retraite mais le cadre de
l'accord était contraint par le
gouvernement c'est la première des
choses donc ensuite en effet certains
syndicats l'ont signé parce que ça
augmente le dispositif dans les plus
petites entreprises je veux dire quand
même que c'est primes on a parlé à
l'instant de la prime Macron en fait ça
ça cache la réalité du partage des
richesses vous l'avez dit ainsi dans
votre introduction je pense que ce sont
les bons mots le partage de la valeur
c'est le c'est la novlang d'aujourd'hui
en réalité il y a un énorme problème de
partage des richesses dans ce pays il y
a une rupture du contrat social dans les
inégalités de rémunération qui explosent
les PDG du CAC 40 sont rémunérés en
moyenne 423 fois le Seigneur que vous
reviendrez dans le débat sur la taxation
sur les super dividendes aussi
évidemment parce que c'est le le nerf de
la guerre en fait là on pourrait
profiter à l'ensemble des Français non
pas seulement du salarié d'entreprise de
où est social cet accord est-il
suffisant à vos yeux d'abord cet accord
est très riche parce que il le traite
beaucoup de sujets il traite aussi de
carrière de profils de carrière de la
notion de valeur qu'est-ce que la valeur
et puis il y a tout un volet
effectivement
partage de la valeur et autres et c'est
un accord qui est compliqué à
retranscrire dans des textes d'ailleurs
le texte qu'on nous propose
n'englobe pas l'ensemble de l'accord il
y a certains points qui seront qui vont
relever du poids réglementaire mais pour
revenir sur le débat sur
fameux super parents pauvre en fait moi
j'entends d'ailleurs c'est dit plusieurs
fois dans l'accord que ces primes ou ce
cette participation je partage de la
valeur ne doit pas se substituer au
salaire quelles sont aujourd'hui elles
se substitue c'est ce que promet en tout
cas le ministre on a eu on a eu un débat
sur notamment ce qu'on appelait la prime
Macron le prime partage de la valeur ça
évolué
on est passé à seuil de 1000 euros on
est monté à 3000 euros jusqu'à 6000
euros
tout simplement une mesure de pouvoir
d'achat ponctuel qui correspondait à
mieux être de l'entreprise à un moment
moi ce que je trouve intéressant cet
accord c'est qu'il ouvre également
l'ensemble des entreprises agnès Bricard
le disait les grandes entreprises à la
limite il y a des grandes entreprises et
puis il y a les petites et on a
l'impression que les salariés sont entre
guillemets un peu moins bien traités
dans les petits entreprises que dans les
grandes entreprises et là cet accord
ouvre le spectre de l'ensemble et la
réflexion sur véritablement la
participation l'obligation c'est quand
même le bénéfice net fiscal au moins
égal à 1% du chiffre d'affaires pendant
trois ans
la difficulté pour une petite entreprise
on connaît mieux moi je connais mieux de
mon expérience
professionnelle je connais mieux ce type
d'entreprise tous ces patrons d'une
étude notariale je le précise tout c'est
très compliqué la participation la mise
en jeu de la participation la réserve de
participation et souvent ce seuil de 50
salariés troublé moi je trouve c'est une
avancée importante parce que ça ouvre la
réflexion sur une évolution d'entreprise
des petites comme les grandes et on l'a
fixé le seuil de mon salarié ça
s'applique que pour les sociétés donc je
vais pas rentrer dans un débat parce
qu'un débat fiscal aussi mais c'est on
partage entre les salariés le super
dividende ce n'était pas du tout du tout
la même chose c'était en quelque sorte
un bénéfice et quand il est dans
l'entreprise il est utile il est investi
il permet de je dirais à la fois de se
développer de faire la transition
énergétique de faire grossir
l'entreprise et si les distribuer il va
aller chez les actionnaires et il perd
un peu sa nature il rémunère les
actionnaires ce qui est tout à fait
normal mais quand on distribue et
c'était l'essence de l'amendement sur
les super dividendes qui a fait couler
beaucoup
de poser de se poser la question de un
bénéfice qui est investi en entreprise
il est utile il est nécessaire et hyper
dividende c'est différent
suivi dans lequel distribué il est utile
pour les actionnaires mais si il déborde
si on peut dire on peut se poser la
question sur sa fiscalité Jean-François
Mathieu ce qui nous regardent se disent
je suis salarié alors évidemment il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de toutes petites
entreprises c'est la grande majorité en
France mais quand même les PME c'est pas
rien dans notre pays ils se disent
combien combien je fais avoir qu'est-ce
que ça va changer très concrètement pour
moi évidemment il y a une certaine
déception parce que
l'intention d'étendre au plus petites
entreprises tous ces dispositifs est
évidemment très bonnes d'ailleurs c'est
le sens de l'histoire si vous voulez en
France comme ça a été rappelé mais déjà
vous remarquerez que je crois qu'on a
reporté à janvier 2025 simplement la
première année ou quelque chose pourrait
apparaître à votre avis
ce serait une bonne idée
non mais le problème principal c'est que
par exemple voyez dans les petites
entreprises qui est prévu c'est au fond
le choix
plein de dispositifs et finalement le
patron choisira celui que qu'il souhaite
a priori retenir il y a beaucoup dans
l'obligation de participation quand même
quand on remplit les conditions elle
devient obligatoire dans l'accord non
vous avez le choix des dispositifs
donc le patron n'est pas obligé il est
tenu par verser la participation 1er
janvier 2025 puisque vous donnez mais
c'est un accord le premier janvier 2025
c'est un accord qui était négocié
patronat salarié mais ce qui dit c'est
au moment où ça s'applique ça peut être
la prime de partage de valeur qui peut
être de 500 qui peut être 2000 qui peut
aller à 3000 et ça peut être un
intéressement et du coup bah il a des
outils il a des outils mais il est
obligé d'en choisir un alors on fait de
la simplification pardonnez-moi de nous
interrompre mais on fait de la
simplification parce que pour faire des
qualités il faut de la simplification on
est bien d'accord donc dès lors qu'on
fait de la simplification on a vu par
exemple sur la prime partage de valeur
qu'on a simplifié au maximum pour que
justement il y ait même plus justement
pour les salariés les neufs 70 qu'on le
retenez on leur donne honnête il y a
plus justement ni c'est ingénieur DS
comme on l'appelle plus de forfait
social non plus dans le cas des
entreprises qui en avaient jusqu'à 20%
au-delà de 250 et ça tient jusqu'au 31
décembre 2023 donc c'est vrai que passer
au 1er janvier 2025 ce qui a été fait
pour l'intéressement c'est que
l'employeur peut décider lui-même ça
s'appelle une décision unilatérale
d'employeur desue il peut décider
lui-même de mettre en place sans accord
de branche sans les deux tiers des
salariés sans son CSE il peut te mettre
en place un accord d'intéressement et on
a fait en sorte de le dématérialiser et
qui trouve en trois pages en un clic
alors
je vous donne la parole pour répondre à
votre question sur les salariés il y a
évidemment une incertitude complète sur
la portée du dispositif combien ça
représentera si pour le salarié
bénéficiaire moyen en France les
différents dispositifs c'est à peu près
2400 euros ou 2005
si vous voulez qu'est-ce qui se passera
dans les petites entreprises on en sait
absolument rien je vais prendre un
exemple
traditionnellement la particip
obligatoire sur les bénéfices il y a une
formule de calcul dit de droit commun or
là on remarque que et renvoyé à la
négociation soit d'entreprise soit de
branches le fait qu'on peut faire mieux
ou moins bien ou moins bien d'ailleurs
qu'en fait mais oui c'est à dire que la
part qui revient au salarié dans le ce
qui finalement la part qui leur revient
on pourrait rappeler la formule de
calcul mais cette part elle peut être
plus faible pour
les grandes entreprises comment ce qui
était déjà vrai dans la loi actuelle sur
l'écran commun et on peut faire mieux on
peut faire que mieux dans la loi
actuelle
c'est pas du gagnant-gagnant mais
forcément non mais dans les petites
entreprises on va pas appliquer
nécessairement la participation qu'on
soit claire on va appliquer soit la PPV
la prime de partage la prime Macron pour
aller l'intéressement avec cette
décision unilatérale de l'employeur
parce que n'oublions pas dans les
petites entreprises ce qui compte c'est
l'homme ou la femme qui dirige une
équipe parfois de 15 20 25 personnes
tout le monde se connaît donc ce qui est
essentiel c'est que
l'employeur va décider unilatéralement
il va avoir des contrats d'intéressement
qui font à peine trois pages c'est
l'URSSAF qui a mis en place de façon
très facile on appuyant sur un clic on a
trois pages qui se présentent on a un
contrat d'intéressement là où avant il y
avait 25 pages d'accord donc attention
n'est pas encore simplifié allez-y
rapidement rapidement je peux dire quand
même que depuis le ce débat sur la prime
Macron ça quand même il y a plus de
prime qui avait auparavant dans les
petits entreprises on a également aussi
une démarche intellectuelle qui fait
qu'on a un véritable dialogue qui se
fait avec ses salariés franchement moi
je constate dans les petits témoignes
entreprises une nécessité d'ouvrir ce
dialogue et je trouve que c'est
intéressant qu'on est cet accord donc il
faut le voir comme une mesure
pédagogique la société de entreprises
des petites entreprises il y a 30 ans
sont plus les mêmes aujourd'hui et moi
je trouve que c'est une avancée et puis
on vous montre un reportage
est un accord collectif un accord
national interprofessionnel moi je vais
pas me substituer au syndicat pour
savoir ce qui est ce qui est bon pour
les salariés je vois que le le
représentant le chef du premier syndicat
de France dit qu'il tient absolument à
ce que cet accord soit transcrit jusqu'à
demain dans la loi jusqu'à demain c'est
pour ça que je le nommais pas mais voyez
donc
moi je ne sais pas mieux que lui ce qui
est important ce qui défend bien
l'intérêt des salariés je pense que
c'est c'est lui qui est la personne
idoine pour savoir comment représenter
porter l'intérêt des salariés c'est une
première chose deuxième chose la France
est un pays particulier quand on regarde
l'évolution du partage céréprofit sur
les trois décennies à partir de 1988 une
fois qu'on a absorbé les chocs
pétroliers on voit que ça se déforme en
faveur des profits on est l'un des rares
pays au monde dans lequel ça se déforme
en faveur des profits alors expliquer ça
veut dire quoi il y a moins pour les
salaires plus pour les profits non non
qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
excusez-moi ça se déforme en faveur des
salariés j'avais mal compris de la masse
salariale la part des profits diminue
dans la valeur ajoutée et nous sommes
l'un des rares pays dans ce cas-là parmi
tous les permis de finir allez-y mais
c'est sec
qui soit dans cette situation donc on
l'a publié dans les meilleures revues du
monde ça a été enfin pour pour ce genre
de choses statistiques dans un débat sur
la semi-cardisation de la société vous
étiez venu sur un débat salaire qui
faisait que on est coincé au niveau des
inégalités salariales qu'est-ce qui se
passe en ce moment les basses salaires
sont protégés le SMIC les protège
complètement on est l'un des rares pays
dans ce cas-là je préside le groupe
d'experts sur le SMIC et dans notre
rapport annuel nous avons publié des
évaluations auxquelles tout le monde
peut se reporter auquel je vous invite à
vous reporter pour
71 en dessous du SMIC les minimum quand
des millimètres branches sont en dessous
du SMIC les gens sont payés le SMIC
évidemment il y a 12 millions de
travailleurs posés
ça écrase la hiérarchie des salaires au
voisinage du SMIC regardez notre rapport
manifestement vous apprendrez des choses
mais la dispersion des salaires a
diminué la dispersion des salaires a
diminué parce que les salaires moyens
n'ont pas augmenté autant que
l'inflation les selles est élevé n'ont
pas augmenté autant que l'inflation les
basses salaires ont augmenté autant que
l'inflation à cause de fixation
au SMIC dans ce pays vivent mal voire
très mal notamment du fait de
l'inflation ils arrivent plus à se
nourrir ils se prive de repas donc c'est
ça la situation sociale du pays je
voulais juste revenir sur la question de
la prime Macron là où c'est de l'arnaque
c'est que vous avez montré de
l'enthousiasme dans votre introduction
se dit on va partager les richesses etc
c'est qu'en fait c'est un dispositif qui
n'est jamais obligatoire donc les
entreprises vont toujours chercher le
moins 10 ans elles peuvent revenir
dessus puisque ces ponctuels alors que
des salaires c'est plus gravés dans le
marbre et donc ce sont des vrais droits
pour les salariés
vraiment au salaire pour 30% des primes
ça a été montré ça se substitue à des
augmentations de salaire ça en fait
environ 1,5 et un arbitrage qui est fait
dans les entreprises en les employeurs
préfèrent une prime plutôt que faire une
augmentation pérenne pour 40 % des prêts
Macron s'étend de sous de 500 euros le
montant moyen c'est 800 euros donc si
vous voulez dans des années où il y a
une telle inflation c'est absolument
elle commence un tout petit peu qui
n'est pas des moindres c'est que il y a
pas de cotisation sociale sur cette
question et que par exemple après Macron
c'est moins 1 milliard tout ce genre de
dispositifs dont on parle c'est moins 9
milliards pour la sécurité sociale et
après on va nous faire une seconde
réforme des retraites en nous disant on
va peut-être aller jusqu'à 65 parce que
on n'est pas encore là
on va justement voir vous le disiez ça
existe déjà dans les petites entreprises
ça s'appelle l'intéressement en fonction
d'objectif c'est un reportage avec les
équipes de France Télévisions d'Alex
Giraud Carlier et Christophe Tixier
regardez c'est concret on en parle juste
après
on septembre dernier les salariés de
cette PME en aménagement paysager ont
touché une prime exceptionnelle de 3000
euros
les prix j'essaie de les mettre un petit
peu de côté soit pour
peut-être la retraite ou quelque chose
comme ça parce qu'on sait pas trop
comment ça va se passer ça peut aider
beaucoup donc c'est comme si ça faisait
aussi un 13e mois le patron veut même la
doubler sous forme de prime
d'intéressement son entreprise fait des
bénéfices et pour lui il est normal de
partager les bons résultats avec ces
salariés la prime sur le partage de la
valeur est une prime qui est
désocialisée et qui n'est pas imposé
pour les salariés donc le salarié qui
reçoit si moi je verse 3 mon entreprise
vers 3000 euros ça veut dire que le
salarié reçoit 3000 euros sans impôts à
payer donc il y a quand même un effet
domaine ici aussi seulement 35 salariés
mais cette agence en communication
touristique a mis en place un accord
d'intéressement la prime peut
représenter jusqu'à deux mois de salaire
de quoi motiver les équipes quand on
parle de collectif vraiment d'une équipe
bah effectivement ça se joue dans
l'intéressement et ensuite oui tout au
long de l'année on le voit parfois des
remarques de personnes qui disent bah
tiens tel bon résultat tel voilà tel bon
résultat tel contrat bah ça va nous
faire aussi un bon intéressant Alice
cabanov la toucher plusieurs fois au
total près de 9000 euros j'ai pu
utiliser les sommes accumulées pour
pouvoir aider à financer l'achat de mon
premier appartement ce partage des
bénéfices que ces deux sociétés ont
devancé pourrait bientôt devenir
obligatoire pour les entreprises à
partir de 11 salariés
voilà c'est pas rien quand même
concrètement dans dans une vie
quotidienne de pouvoir toucher les frais
de bénéficiaires bien sûr mais vous
aviez raison de souligner que la
situation est malheureusement très
inégale entre les très grandes
entreprises qui versent beaucoup et puis
le fait qu'ils passent ce type de
dispositif dans les plus petites ça
c'est certain ce qui était très bien
indiqué dans le reportage et on le sait
très bien c'est que les dispositifs de
parts d'intéressement sont bons pas
seulement pour les salariés parce qu'ils
encaissent tout de suite leur prime
d'intéressement et mais aussi c'est bon
pour la performance des entreprises il y
a un effet positif sur la productivité
qui a été démontré dans les études
internationales je voudrais revenir sur
la question de la négociation j'étais
frappé en lisant l'exposé les motifs de
la loi
de voir que le gouvernement insiste sur
le fait que ils ont utilisé l'article 1
du Code du travail en proposant aux
partenaires dès le mois de septembre je
crois de négocier sur ce sujet et ils
tiennent à le rappeler l'article 1 du
Code du travail ce qu'on appelle la loi
Larcher
simplement pose le fait c'est l'article
1 que avant
tout projet de loi
présenté par le gouvernement portant sur
les questions sociales d'emplois de
travail etc et bien il faut proposer aux
partenaires sociaux de négocier et s'il
le souhaite ils vont le faire et donc au
fond c'est transposé en France qui
existe au niveau européen depuis
longtemps sauf que c'est là que c'est
assez pardon pas cocasse mais on peut
quand même s'amuser ou remarquer que
bien souvent naturellement le
gouvernement se dispense de le faire par
exemple sur les retraites
le fameux index senior c'est une ce sont
des dispositions du Code du travail
vous voyez donc on modifie on fait
quelque chose qui relève des partenaires
sociaux on ne propose jamais à ce
moment-là aux partenaires on leur a pas
dit ah ben tiens en raison de l'article
1 vous allez discuter telle ou tel
aspect en fait de façon générale on ne
le fait pas parce qu'en France à la
différence d'autres pays on n'a pas
assez de culture de le respect des
réseaux sociaux donc les partenaires les
partenaires font un bon accord bon ils
sont contents ils font un accord
majoritaire c'est très bien mais ce
qu'on peut regretter c'est que ce soit
pas plus souvent que effectivement le
politique je vais il y a une dimension
politique importante et un contexte dans
lequel arrive après la crise des
retraites cet accord interprofessionnel
il va être voté c'est presque sûr il y
aura peut-être quelques changements mais
tels que les rapports de force se
présente je crois que les choses sont
dites non il faut pas on reste d'accord
moi je trouve que la méthode est bonne
la méthode est bonne donc il faut il
faut s'en féliciter
je trouve que il va permettre de faire
de la pédagogie aussi dans les
entreprises et de remettre un peu un
équilibre entre les petites et les
grandes entreprises parce que souvent on
n'est pas dans le même monde en tant que
salarié et ça me semble important il y a
aussi un volet actionnariat pouvoir être
actionnaire avec les distributions
gratuites aussi et je crois que
l'entreprise il y aura aussi des
associés vous voyez cette entrepreneur
que vous voyez peut-être qu'il a déjà
identifié dans ces salariés des gens qui
qui reprendront sur l'entreprise donc je
crois qu'il faut qu'on vraiment on
s'ouvre et je trouve que la méthode qui
a été prise par les partenaires sociaux
et la bonne méthode qu'il faut il faut
compléter il faut discuter il faut
vraiment il faut saisir cette chance
j'entends ce que vous dites sur les
salaires l'écrasement le SMIC
l'écrasement des de la de la grille des
salaires bien sûr que c'est que c'est un
sujet bien sûr qu'on va pas substituer
ces primes au salaire on est tout à fait
d'accord mais une prime quand
l'entreprise va bien elle verse elle
verse une prime le à partir du moment
pour l'entreprise un chiffre d'affaires
qui en progression on n'est pas sur des
primes on est sur une augmentation des
salaires une discussion des grilles de
salaire si vous avez
le fait d'avoir décroché un bon contrat
qui vous permet de d'avoir un chiffre
d'affaires un peu supérieur et donc
dégager c'est peut-être d'exceptionnel
c'est pas dans la continuité mais je
crois que par à coup on va bâtir des
vrais projets d'entreprise même pour les
petites entreprises je vous vois aussi
de la tête c'est un pas en avant je peux
clairement dire sur ce que vous pour
terminer
l'augmentation de chiffre d'affaires
dans des entreprises de 11 à 49 salariés
à du sens et c'est un critère qui a été
retenu dans les simplifications qui sont
proposées pour l'intéressement donc je
voudrais le dire parce que c'est
vraiment un point essentiel et nous
expert-comptable on est en train de le
dire à nos PME c'est-à-dire là où on est
vraiment présent à 95% du PME en leur
dit attention n'oubliez pas prime de
partage de valeur et intéressement
simplifie c'est dit merci on va
s'arrêter là on va regarder vous il y a
un dire un tout petit mot monsieur le
professeur je sais que vous
[Musique]
l'article L1 du Code du travail
l'article est l'un du Code du travail
transforme le Parlement transforme
pardon les partenaires sociaux en
prélégateur mais on peut pas enlever
bien sûr au Parlement la possibilité
d'amander un texte il y a une véritable
difficulté là à laquelle il faut
concurrence de mesure qu'on soit de
gauche de droite n'importe où
démocratie sociale versus démocratie
parlementaire on s'arrête là peut-être
vous reviendrez pour cette autre débat
on aurait pu dire beaucoup de choses
aussi le rachat d'action promis par le
Président de la République on n'entend
plus parler de ça peut-être ça va
s'inviter dans ce débat dans l'hémicycle
merci merci d'être venu débattre sur LCP
vous restez avec moi Jean-Paul Mathey
dans une petite dizaine de minutes les
parties pris de nos affranchis ce soir
regarde sur la guerre de Richard Verdi
qui revient tout juste du don-basse le
front ukrainien en pleine
contre-offensive retour avec Jean-Rémy
Baudot sur la vidéo
sordide de la violente à Bordeaux bras
de fer local et faits divers national et
puis dans Bourbon Express ce soir de
quoi nous parler vous Stéphanie despier
et bien on parlera de la majorité qui
veut remplacer Éric Coquerel à la tête
de la commission des finances on verra
ça à tout à l'heure d'abord avec vous
Jean-Paul Mathey on va revenir sur votre
année de président du groupe moderne à
l'Assemblée vous êtes d'un naturel
discret pas franchement d'ailleurs à
vous entendre en direct vous êtes dans
l'ombre mais c'est dans l'ombre que
parfois on est le meilleur des
politiques très proches de François
Bayrou aussi dont vous avez l'amour des
Pyrénées en partage et puis comme lui
vous êtes capable de quelques coups de
griffes à l'Allier macronique macroniste
quand vous le jugez
utile mais à quoi ça sert pas forcément
pas grand chose pour le moment vous nous
le direz la vitesse est signée ce soir
pierre Michael Carniel on en parle
ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Jean-Paul Mattei c'est
parce que vous êtes à la tête d'une
formation stratégique et surtout
indispensable pour consolider une
majorité présidentielle à l'Assemblée le
groupe modem un groupe charnière situé
entre Renaissance et horizon en 5 ans
vous êtes le seul groupe du bloc à avoir
gagné des députés passant de 47 à 51
élus Jean-Paul Mattei vous rentrez à
l'Assemblée nationale en 2017 en tant
que député des Pyrénées-Atlantiques
avant de prendre la tête du groupe 5 ans
plus tard vous êtes également le bras
droit de François Bayrou comme lui vous
êtes un sans triste historique
la pierre angulaire de votre parcours
politique c'est la défense de la justice
sociale vous l'avez montré en défendant
une proposition de loi sur la taxation
des super dividendes soutenu par les
insoumis les ennemis jurés de
renaissance
on est vraiment sur une notion de super
dividende plus 20% par rapport à la
moyenne des dividendes ça incite les
entreprises à investir leur bénéfice
dans le développement dans la transition
donc je pense que c'est quelque chose de
vertueux voilà est-ce que on peut se
poser ce problème
Jean-Paul Mattei vous êtes un homme
politique à l'ancienne loin des coups
d'éclat et du buzz médiatique vous
préférez plutôt les compromis en
coulisses fort de votre expérience en
tant que notaire qui a fait de vous un
expert du foncier vous vous rêvez
maintenant en tant que ministre du
logement lors d'un prochain remaniement
encore faut-il que le futur gouvernement
ne penche pas trop pas droite une
hypothèse qui n'est pas au goût de
François Bayrou pour ma part en tout cas
je trouverai que un virage comme il est
appelé par les uns ou par les autres
serait le contraire de ce que nous avons
proposé aux Français
alors nous avons une question pour vous
Jean-Paul Mattei quand la majorité pour
adopter un texte se joue à une
quarantaine de voix la coalition avec la
droite n'est-elle pas la seule solution
pour sortir de l'immobilisme
alors réponse à cette question la
coalition avec la droite aujourd'hui
pour sortir des blocages au Parlement
c'est pas la solution la solution
écouter quand on s'est engagé en 2017
derrière Emmanuel Macron
il y avait une offre politique on
connaît depuis pas mal d'années
notamment et François Bayrou et même
antérieurement avec Valéry Giscard
d'Estaing sur une cécité du gouverner la
France au centre donc le centre c'est le
centre donc c'est à la fois un peu
droite et un peu de gauche aussi voilà
donc
politique il manque une quarantaine de
voix 38 exactement
et quand on fait la nouvelle lecture de
notre hémicycle
je regrette moi il y a la nupes qui est
je dirais une organisation politique et
qui a fonctionné qui a une certaine
réussite mais on sent les membres de la
nuit passe un peu bloquer pour essayer
de s'ouvrir de discuter moi je crois
qu'il faut que
son capacité de s'affranchir un peu et
trouver des ponts un peu à droite un peu
à gauche et trouver des ponts en un an
on a regardé le bilan de cette première
année 64% des projets de loi ont été
adoptés grâce aux voix des républicains
la droite n'est-elle pas déjà le
partenaire naturel d'Emmanuel Macron on
a des je dirais des membres du LR qui
sont tout à fait responsables qui ont
été aux affaires et qui se connaissent
qu'on a des membres du gouvernement qui
ont été de la même famille un premier
ministre LR à Matignon Gérard Larcher
tiens c'est pas le plus radical à droite
c'est non pour vous sinon je le sens pas
je vous dis franchement c'est pas
l'esprit dans lequel on était en 2017 et
on a envie de continuer cette majorité
ça veut dire quoi c'est un casus belli
pour vous non votre ryez pas des textes
s'ils étaient négociés avec leurs
compétence du Président de la République
c'est pas de la mienne nous on est dans
la majorité
c'est pas une question de personne moi
je dois vous dire on travaille très bien
avec Elizabeth borne moi je travaille
très très bien qu'ils avaient deborde
vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure elle a se
positionnement un peu à gauche dans les
côtes cette capacité de oui d'écoute et
de reste après le 14 juillet je pense
que encore une fois c'est pas moi de le
dire mais je pense qu'on a besoin de
stabilité et qu'on a besoin de rebondir
avec l'équipe alors peut-être
remanier j'en sais rien c'est vraiment
pas le sujet c'est vraiment il faut
qu'on travaille qu'on se concentre et
qu'on arrive à cette bourniste vous
savez que ça existe ce mot maintenant ça
vous fait sourire allez parlons du bilan
de la majorité un an après les textes
passent mais à quel prix celui de
s'éloigner un peu plus à chaque fois de
notre capacité à réformer est-ce que
vous savez qui a dit ça
et ben je vais vous le dire c'est Naima
Moutchou la vice-présidente du groupe
horizon le groupe d'Edouard Philippe à
l'Assemblée nationale dans un papier du
monde aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle a pas
un petit peu raison
alors on a vécu on a vécu une période
notamment avec la réforme des retraites
on n'a pas pu et même les textes
financiers qu'on a qu'on a adopté dans
le cas de du 49-3 là je savais que notre
groupe on était assez favorable d'aller
au vote sur les retraites ensuite moi je
considère malgré ce qu'on veut bien dire
il y a eu un vote c'est à dire il n'y a
pas eu de censure du gouvernement donc à
la fin de votre des 577
si vraiment si vraiment on avait on le
voit bien d'ailleurs regardez le rapport
du corps aujourd'hui on considère qu'il
y a quand même des avancées
dans ce texte donc voilà je crois qu'il
faut pas qu'on se pose un peu sur ce
texte on a nous revendiquer une clause
de revoyure dans le texte des retraites
pour 2027 je pense que le temps viendra
d'ailleurs les gens constatent
aujourd'hui quand ils font leur calcul
que les 64 ans c'est pas aujourd'hui ça
sera en octobre 2027 ça sera 63 on
pourra remettre la réforme sur le métier
si nécessaire à mon avis c'est une
réforme qui est pas stabilisée du fait
qu'il y a plein de paramètres et qu'il
faut chaque fois réfléchir sur son
efficacité alors au modem on connaît
votre attachement à la justice sociale
et au juste la juste répartition des
efforts demandés à chacun c'est un peu
la DN du centrisme à la François Bayrou
mais à la Jean-Paul Mattei également
votre taxe sur les super dividendes on
en a parlé qui avait fait sensation et
tomber dans les oubliettes de Bercy
qu'avez-vous concrètement obtenu sur le
fond Jean-Paul Mathei je pense que j'ai
obtenu pendant qu'on en débattre qu'on
en discute qu'on se pose des
interrogations sur la contribution des
revenus du travail par rapport au revenu
du capital je crois que on a on a fait
des réformes en 2017 qui était qui ont
été utiles et nécessaire maintenant
est-ce qu'on peut se poser et dire
est-ce que on peut pas essayer de
rééquilibrer
ça veut dire quoi
agnèsf vert par exemple c'est
l'économiste qui a travaillé sur
contact les choses immobiles on n'a pas
forcément la trésorerie pour faire face
moi je considère qu'il y a d'autres
outils comme sur les flux sur les
plus-values et autres sur l'immobilier
c'est un sujet pour relancer je pense le
logement il faut qu'on s'interroge et
qu'on se pose des bonnes questions on a
un système qui favorise la rétention
foncière qui favorise pas la circulation
bien évidemment sur les résidences
principales il faut pas y toucher parce
que on peut on est dans un système
d'exonération on essaie dans le parcours
résidentiel normal de toute personne qui
construit sa vie on est dans une très
très grave crise du logement j'en
profite des voitures
d'intérêt qui augmente il y a très peu
de construction par rapport aux besoins
il y a eu ce conseil national de la
Fondation avec tous les acteurs très en
colère après les annonces qui ont été
jugées dans la presse qu'il fallait à
choc fiscal sur le logement je le pense
bon on en est pas là quand j'ai écouté
la première ministre et et Bruno Luère
en un n'est pas encore là mais vous
dites dans les échos vous êtes référence
à cet article que le logement est
maltraité aujourd'hui mais parce que il
y a deux choses l'immobilier c'est un
quand c'est loué à long terme au titre
d'une résidence principale pour des gens
qui veulent se loger
par rapport location meublée saisonnière
Airbnb là on a moi je considère à ce
moment-là le logement devient vertueux
c'est d'ailleurs que l'investisseur qui
veut mettre sur le marché des biens pour
les louer pour pour des familles avec un
loyer encadré avec une recherche aussi
de qualité environnementale
devrait être mieux traité c'est aussi
important comme investissement vous
défendez un statut d'investit
d'investisseurs immobiliers si je
comprends bien vous au modem vous n'êtes
pas complètement allergique à l'impôt
sur des plus riches et comment vous
expliquer que ce gouvernement soit
manifestement allergique alors on a
l'impression que vous considérez
en quelque sorte pas étrange très élevé
on rappelle que la première tranche est
à 11 même avant on était en dessous la
première si les 51 députés que vous
pilotez qui sont absolument
indispensables au macronie seront
entendus cette fois parce qu'on a
l'impression que c'est pas toujours le
cas il faut que je vous pose la question
sur Richard Ferrand parce que le temps
nous est compté est-ce que vous l'avez
compris l'ancien président de
l'Assemblée nationale dans le Figaro à
la question regrettez-vous qu'Emmanuel
Macron ne puisse pas se représenter en
2027 il répond qu'il regrette tout ce
qui brille de la libre expression de la
souveraineté populaire dans la
Constitution comme la limitation dans le
temps du mandat présidentiel changeons
tout cela dit-il avant de rétropédaler
sur Sud Radio
bon je pense que les réactions
sont ainsi quinquennat législatives
juste après une élection limitation à
deux mandats ainsi c'est ainsi
Macron Emmanuel Macron le président
Emmanuel Macron disparaîtra pas la scène
politique
d'avoir dit ça c'est je sais pas je sais
pas du tout mais on peut s'interroger
sur la limitation des mandats quand on a
des gens de qualité et si le suffrage
universel leur donne encore leur chance
c'est vrai mais bon c'est comme ça je
crois qu'il faut surtout pas revenir sur
cette règle de demanda consécutifs je
dis pas de monde à consécutif voilà donc
il faudra
souhaité d'ailleurs Nicolas Sarkozy d'un
tout petit mot François Bayrou candidat
en 2027 vous le souhaitez
alors vous savez François Bayrou était
candidat trois fois au présidentielle il
a il a la capacité je dirais
à assumer ce combat parce que c'était
c'est un véritable combat on verra je
dirais le temps n'est pas n'est pas
n'est pas c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui prudent prudent sur cette
question
de d'être candidat et d'être président
de la République mais c'est pas le sujet
d'aujourd'hui merci pour rester avec moi
vous allez voir ils vont vous faire
réagir nos affranchis pour leur parti
pris qu'on accueille tout de suite
bienvenue à vous
Richard Werly qui revient du crâne je le
disais j'aurai niveau d'eau de France
Info le brief politique tous les matins
7h24 installer vous préparez vos cartes
blanches on commence comme chaque soir
par Bourbon Express l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce soir
par Stéphanie Despierre bonsoir
Stéphanie bonsoir Myriam mais l'histoire
du jour c'est celle d'un député insoumis
Éric Coquerel qui est dans le viseur des
macronistes alors Éric Coquerel est
aussi président de la puissante
commission des finances de l'Assemblée
depuis plusieurs semaines il est la
cible de toutes les critiques du camp
présidentiel Antoine de fond
rappelez-vous les débats sur la
proposition de loi du pour abroger la
réforme des retraites et plus
précisément sur sa recevabilité au
regard de l'article 40 de la
Constitution alors avant qu'il y a
LeBron Pivet mette un terme au débat
Eric Coquerel avait dit recevable une
erreur selon la majorité qui ne perd pas
une occasion de le répéter depuis
chacun a fait son devoir à l'exception
hélas du président de la commission des
finances si vous tenez mes chers
collègues à sanctionner quelqu'un dans
cette affaire pour non respect de la
Constitution vous tenez votre homme la
vraie galinette cendrée c'est le
président de la commission des finances
la galinette cendrée alors autant vous
dire que ça ne fait pas rire tout le
monde Myriam et pas la nupes qui s'agace
qui s'inquiète elle a peur que la
majorité veuille remplacer Éric Coquerel
alors hier les présidents des quatre
groupes de gauche ont envoyé un courrier
officiel à la présidente de l'Assemblée
pour dénoncer des pressions des attaques
contre le président de la commission des
finances et un traitement inacceptable
la gauche accuse pelle mais les députés
les ministres la première ministre et la
présidente du groupe Renaissance ce qui
fait sourire jaune Aurore berger
la meilleure réponse est de regarder ce
qui se passe dans l'hémicycle je crois
que ni les menaces ni les intimidations
ni les provocations ne viennent de la
majorité alors est-ce qu'elle a un plan
caché la majorité pour évincer vos
crèmes oui Myriam Ali réfléchit très
sérieusement en théorie les postes clés
à l'Assemblée nationale donc la
présidence de la commission des finances
sont attribuées pour un an seulement
mais ces postes ne sont que très
rarement remise en jeu les titulaires
les gardent en général durant 5 ans mais
cette fois une partie du groupe
Renaissance est très remontée et bien
décidé à tout faire pour qu'Eric
Coquerel ne puisse pas garder son poste
jusqu'en 2027 et donc à refaire une
élection il est partisan il ne fait pas
son job disent les spécialistes du
budget ont lieu à l'Assemblée on estime
qu'en un an il y a 130 amendements sur
lesquels Éric Coquerel aurait dû mettre
son veto or il ne l'a pas fait je n'ai
aucun scrupule à déterrer la hache de
guerre nous expliquait tout à l'heure
une députée Renaissance inverse d'autres
sont beaucoup plus prudents Myriam si on
touche à Éric Coquerel il faut tout
remettre à plat c'est tous les
présidents de commission les
vice-présidents etc etc il y a ton
intérêt
Eric verte l'ancien chef de la
commission à des finances anciens
républicains désormais à Renaissance et
voient très écoutées n'y est pas du tout
favorable bon c'est je comprends rien
c'est plus facile à dire qu'à faire oui
et c'est ça qui fait hésiter une partie
du camp présidentiel le règlement permet
une nouvelle élection ou la dit mais ce
serait très inhabituel l'autre règle
plus fondamentale car écrite dans la
Constitution veut que le président de
cette commission des finances soit un
député d'opposition pour la respecter
l'usage veut aussi que la majorité ne
prenne pas par au vote il faudrait donc
remettre en cause ses usages ça fait
beaucoup de conditions ce qui explique
pourquoi le principal intéressé Eric
coquelet Eric Coquerel n'est pas très
inquiet
la majorité peut se présenter contre moi
donc il faut que quelqu'un l'opposition
qui veuille le faire puis j'ai entendu
aussi monsieur marlex ce week-end dire
que les républicains ne joueraient pas
ce jeu-là et sans quelqu'un d'une
opposition vous lance mettre en face de
moi je vois pas très bien comment ça
peut être fait
même pas peur parce qu'en fait Myriam il
faut en place en opposition mais pas
trop car soutenu par les macronistes
mais pas complètement des avoués par
l'opposition bref un mouton à cinq
pattes le casse-tête et l'art pour la
majorité qu'il n'a donc pas tout à fait
définitivement arrêté son plan et là
encore un peu de temps pour y réfléchir
car s'il y a une nouvelle élection ce ne
sera pas avant octobre et vous monsieur
Mattei vous en pensez quoi
je connais bien Rico Krell j'ai eu
l'occasion de faire un rapport lors du
dernier mandat avec lui sur la peau
universelle on sait très bien entendu
je considère qu'il aurait dû déclarer et
recevable le texte au titre de l'article
40 ce texte là
l'iode parce que c'était vraiment un
texte financier qui visait à un projet à
notre texte financier il l'a pas fait
l'assume est-ce que pour autant il faut
changer de prise dans la commission des
finances moi je suis pas favorable je
suis sur la ligne des riverse c'est pas
à nous de choisir le président de
l'opposition je crois que le message est
bien passé donc merci
quelque chose me dit qu'il est pas prêt
de partir avec Coquerel on continue
merci beaucoup Stéphanie toujours la
politique j'aurais mis vos doigts vous
vouliez revenir sur cette terrible
agression à Bordeaux qui agite le monde
politique depuis 24 heures oui vous avez
peut-être vu ces images filmées par un
interphone des images extrêmement
chaudes d'une rare violence on ne les
diffusera pas ce soir pour respecter les
victimes mais on y voit une septua
génère et sa petite fille agressée sur
le pas de leur porte à Bordeaux ça s'est
passé lundi soir agression abject lâche
dont la diffusion en fait ne doit rien
au hasard puisque c'est d'abord un jeu
de politique locale c'est Nicolas
Florian qui diffuse en premier cette
vidéo lui c'est l'ancien maire LR de
Bordeaux pour lui en fait l'occasion est
trop belle de dénoncer le manque de
sécurité dans la ville alors que depuis
et bien il y a eu un maire écologiste
pierre urique donc obligé de réagir qui
dénonce de son côté les récupérations
politiques écoutez
c'est la première fois que je vois de
telles images sur Bordeaux pour voir la
réalité en face c'est la réalité en face
et qu'aujourd'hui à Bordeaux la sécurité
se dégrade l'état proposé à la ville de
Bordeaux d'avoir un contrat de sécurité
depuis deux ans il est toujours pas
signé je n'entends pas commenter des
réactions qui
non seulement sont-elles descente
une centaine dignes je pense à des
réactions de récupération politique
locale et nationale voilà et en parlant
de récupération ça va vraiment venir
puisque ça va sortir de la sphère locale
petite parenthèse l'agresseur a été
arrêtée très rapidement il souffrirait
de problèmes psychiatriques mais c'est
donc un jeu local qui devient une
affaire assez vite nationale
politique aujourd'hui alors mettons
d'abord les choses au clair le
décryptage politique ne doit pas faire
oublier le fond de la faire oui cet acte
est insupportable on n'ira pas du côté
des des relativistes qui disent que
c'est un fait divers comme un autre non
c'est absolument traumatisant pour
autant regardant les ressorts politiques
qui ont été mis à jour avec une petite
touche de racisme petite touche de
racisme oui le suspect alors on le voit
pas parce qu'on n'a pas vu les images
mais on peut le dire il est noir et ça
fait évidemment les affaires de
l'extrême droite très vite Marine Le Pen
fustige l'insécurité je cite aggravé par
le chaos migratoire immigration
insécurité le la boucle est bouclée
selon elle Eric Zemmour utilise par
défaut le terme de migrants
comme disait Bourdieu cette histoire
elle dit beaucoup de notre société de
nos politiques qui seraient peut-être
inspirées de d'abord répondre aux
questions posées par ce genre de dossier
merci en voilà un parti pris qu'est-ce
qu'elle vous inspire cette affaire et la
manière dont elle a été récupérée il
faut avoir beaucoup de recul je partage
un peu et de décence probablement il
faut il faut prendre du temps de pas
s'emballer regarder avec beaucoup
d'humanité penser aux victimes et autres
mais sur qu'on les prépare l'émotion
mais je crois qu'il faut chaque fois
être très très posé et ne pas réagir à
chaud c'est certainement la très
mauvaise méthode et on achète lucide
avec vous Richard Verdi je le disais
vous reveniez vous revenez du crâne vous
avez une carte blanche ce soir pour nous
parler de cette région de Donetsk où se
déroule la couper-offensive et vous
vouliez nous parler de ces forces qui
défilent l'Europe les Ukrainiens les
appels les orques effectivement les
orques c'est un nom que je n'avais
jamais entendu prononcé jusque là à
propos de l'Ukraine ni à Paris ni à
Bruxelles ni au sein de l'OTAN alors
pour moi peut-être comme pour vous
c'était d'abord un cétacé c'est aussi et
là on se rapproche du champ de bataille
une créature fantastique du Seigneur des
Anneaux chez Tolkien les orques sont les
plus cruels il a fallu que je me
rapproche de la ligne de front j'y étais
encore dimanche pour comprendre que
derrière ce terme se cache une autre
armée c'est les soldats de Poutine c'est
ainsi qu'il se nomme eux-mêmes et c'est
comme ça que tous les Ukrainiens les
désignent tous sur le front vous parlent
des orques le terme désigne pêle-mêle
l'armée régulière les conscrits les
hommes de la ministre Wagner ou les
détenus libérés par le Kremlin pour
aller combattre en première ligne c'est
un mot qui a évidemment valeur
d'avertissement et d'appel au secours
parce que ne pas aider l'Ukraine c'est
la laisser se faire dévorer par les
orques le problème de ces orques et bien
c'est qu'on ne les voit pas ces jours-ci
très peu de prisonniers russes sont
montrés au journaliste l'information sur
la contre-offensive est verrouillée j'ai
pu l'expérimenter on ne peut pas accéder
aux zones de combat immédiate mais les
orques ils sont là ils rôdent j'ai vu
Yelena une vieille femme dont on a vu
l'image rencontrer près de châssis Viard
vous savez ce localité ou un journaliste
de lifep a été tué et bien il a devant
moi cette phrase surréaliste pour elle
le jour des orcs c'est le vendredi c'est
chaque vendredi pareil elle m'a montré
un impact dont but dans son jardin on
était samedi la veille elle était sous
un déluge de feu tombé du ciel vous
allez me dire que Sanry Marien que c'est
totalement habillé aberrant et bien
c'est ça la guerre du crâne c'est des
tirs de canon le vendredi ou bien vous
explique-t-on après l'heure du déjeuner
quand les orques sont rassasiés ces
orques évidemment terrifie toutes les
populations en Ukraine oui et parler des
orques c'est aussi signifié que ces
russes là ceux qui sont de l'autre côté
dans les tranchées au cerveau lavé par
la propagande poutinienne ce ne sont
plus les mêmes russes cette même vieille
dame Yelena et bien c'est une enfant de
l'ex-Union soviétique elle est
russophone elle est née dans ce village
à l'ouest de doniesk elle m'a dit
qu'elle ne comprend rien à cette guerre
elle sait juste que le vendredi le ciel
devient l'enfer et on m'a aussi parlé de
contrefensive de bourre repris d'avancer
ukrainienne moi c'est la guerre des
orques une guerre invisible que j'ai vu
à coup de canon de mortier domicile et
des heures qui sont bien mieux
retranchés équipé bien plus difficile à
déloger qu'en 2022 désorgues qui épile
ennemis et les civils à l'aide de drones
j'ai pu le constater comme le font les
Ukrainiens des orgues dans les obus
pulvérisent les hôpitaux comme celui de
torrent le 7 juin dernier une cité
minière la guerre des orques c'est celle
que l'Europe rationnelle raisonnable ne
comprendra peut-être jamais une guerre
qu'un tantiste ukrainien juché sur son
char planqué sous le sous les arbres
parce qu'il avait été endommagé ma
résumé d'une phrase nous étions des
hommes les orques de Poutine nous ont
tous transformés en animaux
merci pour ce témoignage merci beaucoup
Richard Verly
l'inhumanité de la guerre c'est
l'humanité je suis glacé parce que ce
que vous dites c'est très impressionnant
bien sûr
on s'arrête là merci beaucoup Richard
werli Jean Rémi Baudot Stéphanie
Despierre à très vite et merci à vous
monsieur le Président Mattei d'être
passé nous voir en direct sur LCP soirée
documentaire qui commence maintenant
avec Jean-Pierre Gratien rester avec
nous très belle soirée à demain
[Musique]